Good morning and welcome to the NCBI Minute:
An Updated PubMed is on its way!
Today I am here with Kathy Canese and Jessica
Chan from the PubMed team. My name is Marie
Collins and I will be doing the talking but
Jessica will be doing the typing of the questions
pod. If we don't get to your questions we
have a lot of people on the line. If we don't
get to questions you can always reach out
to us and send feedback after the webinar.
Today I want to talk about the new PubMed.
I'm going to start with the roadmap or timeline
because that seems to be the number one question
that we get from folks. I will talk about
the goals, the Agile development model, why
we built PubMed, a new PubMed and how we've
built a new PubMed. I will talk about the
features that have already been released in
PubMed Labs and features that are still to
come, the responsive design of the new PubMed.
Then I have a couple of slides about communication
and planning for the transition to the new
PubMed
I am starting with the Mission Statement or
just overarching goal for the new PubMed.
We are transforming PubMed into a modern hub
with a fast, reliable, and intuitive searh
that connects people to the world's leading
sources of biomedical information. And when
you read this statement I think every time
I read this statement I think this new PubMed
is really in line with of the goals of NIH,
the goals of NLM strategic plan for sure,
and it sort of captures of the world we all
work in every day here at NCBI. This is pretty
much what we do.
The roadmap, if you are not familiar with
the new PubMed this will be completely new
to you. If you have seen a previous presentation
or read a previous article about the new PubMed,
this will be a shift for you. The plan as
it stands right now, which I think is a pretty
solid plan is to have PubMed Labs, which is
running right now and you can see of the yellow
on the top bar. It's up and running but not
the current production PubMed. January2020
we plan to make PubMed Labs the default production
PubMed, so we're arriving at PubMed early
next year; you'll arrive at the new PubMed.
Current production PubMed at that time will
remain archived and available for several
months.
I will talk briefly about the goals for the
new PubMed. Again, people who have seen other
presentations, this may be a little repetitive
but I'm also hoping to reach people who were
not aware at all we were going to a new PubMed.
We are shifting PubMed to a modern cloud architecture
focusing on a high-quality search. The new
PubMed will be fast and reliable, at least
as fast and reliable as current production
PubMed. It will deliver a modern experience
and our overarching goal for this development
is we build a system that is beloved. People
love current PubMed. We really hope they are
going to love new PubMed when it launches.
We've built this in an Agile development environment.
This means we have released a minimal viable
product within enough features for early users
and at the same time we established an environment
to capture feedback for future development.
We released new features frequently and we
pay continuous attention to technical excellence
and the good design.
Who did we talk to in building this new PubMed?
We talked clinicians; researchers; professors,
librarians, journalists, grant writers, bio
curators, Health Advocates and PubMed team
members. Our research our usability testing
our interviews have been exhaustive and they
have been ongoing. In an Agile environment
you can continue to do the usability testing
throughout the lifecycle of the project. Just
two weeks ago we had usability experts at
the Clinical Center at NIH showing folks the
PubMed Lab on the mobile device and testing
the usability there, getting feedback that
will further will further inform our development.
This is a huge endeavor. It's a huge project.
It's a huge shift from the current production
PubMed moving into the cloud. It's not just
an interface refresh. However, what our users
will see is the interface refresh. I'm starting
here and the bulk of my presentation will
actually be on the features of this new PubMed.
I am going to start with what you will see
on this new interface when you are in PubMed
Labs if looking at a single citation, and
then I will go back to you run a research,
and you've results and all of the things you
can do with you can do with the full result
set.
I have put the URL here if you would like
to open a Web browser and play along. You
can look at labs either for the first time
or again if you have been there before. I
first time or again if you have been there
before. I am going to start if you were to
run a search in PubMed Lab and look at a single
citation. I will show you some of the things
that you'll see there.
Here I am looking at an abstract in PubMed
Labs. You can see we added this navigation
from within the single result so you can go
from one result to the next without going
back to your full results list.
If you hover over the previous or next button,
you will see little bit of details for the
citation that either comes before or after
this one. Also when looking at a single abstract
you'll see we have the full text links. You
have publisher links, the PMC link if article
is available in PMC. Now we have added the
library link out using outside tools. You
can see up to five library icons. If you are
affiliated with the hospital as well as a
university, for example you can display the
icons for all of the institution you are affiliated
with and take advantage of all of those subscriptions.
We have a new cite buton that I"ll show you
a little bit later. We've added the cite but
not was show you a little bit later. We've
added the Favorites button. You can share
to Twitter, Facebook or grab a perma link.
And we have page navigation. You can use the
navigation menu to jump right onto similar
articles or references or the link out menu,
or you can scroll through the abstract page
to see the rest of the information that is
below the abstract.
Back to our results page. There is a lot going
on here. I am hoping today what you will see
of PubMed Labs will assure you that it is
feature-rich, and we will go through this,
each of these features, most of these features
in a little more detail. We have the results
by year graph. You can click on the arrows
to expand it. You can use the circles there
on the bottom to narrow or broaden your range.
We have the save, e-mail, and more actions
menu. We have a BestMatch sort order that
you can easily toggle to most recent. You
can change your view from the summary view
that you see in front of you on the screen
to the full abstract view. You can see here
that we have added these snippets with highlights
so you can scroll through your results and
see why this result was returned, get a little
bit more information before you go into the
full abstract.
We have filters. Very recently we added the
ability to customize this filters menu which
I will talk about in a m inute. You You can
create an alert. You can go to advanced search.
And under each item as well as when you are
looking at a single abstract you can use that
cite feature or share the article.
I'm going to start with a cite feature because
it's very exciting and new and something we
have never had in PubMed before. You can grab
the citation for an abstract with that cite
button. The text is text is already highlighted.
You can hit control-C or the copy button.
You can download that citation as a RIS file.
The formats available are AMA, MLA, APA and
NLM format. You could share by share by clicking
on the link. Again, it's Twitter, Facebook
or grabbing the perma link.
You can save an e-mail results as you do today.
I selected two citations. I can click on either
save or e-mail. The options for saving to
file would be to save all of the results on
the page, all of the results of your search
or the selected items. The formats available
there are summary, RIS, PMID list or abstract.
The e-mail options you can e-mail all of the
results on the page or selected items in either
the summary or abstract, either text or just
the text format called the rich text.
There is a more actions menu, this is where
you will find the send to features. You can
send your items either to the clipboard or
to a collection. The clipboard allows you
to add up to 500 citations to a temporary
clipboard, and it pops up, I think the messages
in PubMed Labs, the way that they appear on
the screen you don't tend to overlook them
as much as you might in production PubMed.
I sort of like this, when you add the two
items to the clipboard, you see a message
there and also where red arrow is you now
that clipboard link appears also with advanced
search and alert, so it's easy to remember
you have a clipboard and to navigate to your
clipboard and see what you have been collecting
there.
Collections you can add up to 1000 citations
in a collection in your My NCBI account. I
personally prefer collections because of they
are persistent. This will be my first plug
if you don't have one register for my NCBI
account.
Filters, as I said we have default filters
on the left side bar menu. I think the filters
are little more intuitive in PubMed Labs where
you can tell whether they are selected or
not selected because they have the empty checkbox.
Right now I don't have any filters selected.
I can add more filters to this menu by clicking
on the the additional filters button. A pop-up
will appear and I can select from the various
categories that you see here.
In this case I have gone to the age category,
selected two more filters, and when I click
on apply they will appear in my filters menu
and I can check them to select or deselect
them as I need to when I am searching.
Speaking of filters and speaking of being
Agile, my NCBI custom filters were rolled
into production PubMed Labs yesterday, so
this slide I added to the slide deck yesterday
as well.
Now if you are logged into my NCBI account
and you have set up custom filters you will
see them appear there above the results by
year. We sort of felt if you have these filters,
you want want to be able to access them, so
there they are for you.
Advanced search and history is available.
This is a feature that is not used by everyone,
but loved by the folks who do use it. It allows
you to search specific fields. You can show
an index if you have a search term and want
to click on show index, it will Let you see
all of the results if you were to execute
that search.
It allows you to build complex searches, and
it's a powerful tool for advanced users.
The search history which appears under the
advanced search at the bottom half of the
screen allows you to view and download your
search history. You can compare the results
of various searches, sort of a one-stop or
you can see a list of all of the searches
you have done. You can combine previous searches,
view search details and download your search
history. Here you can see that I have run
three searches and the fourth search was that
combination of the previous searches. Then
I can take that search, number four and add
it to a subheading, and really have a good
way of tracking what I have done and what
my results have been from each of the searches.
The search details you will find here on the
advanced search page, and if you click on
that caret in any one of the searches you
will see that expands to your search details
you are used to seeing.
And this will have the search translation
for you. You can see these are the details
of my fifth search which was was the most
complicated, and it keeps everything that
I have sort of rolled up into this search
is presented here for you.
You can create search alerts. This is very
similar to the functionality that we have
now. You can run a search and then choose
to create an alert. You get to name your search.
You can receive e-mail updates, specify the
frequency, specify the format of your e-mail,
and how many items you would like to see in
the e-mail message.
I am going to talk for a minute about the
fact that the new PubMed Labs is a truly responsive
site. This means the features you see on the
desktop will also be available on your mobile
device. Now, this development has to be optimized
for mobile device be sure when you build your
responsive design and when you think about
how it's going to act on to act on a mobile
device, you don't want it to override any
native phone features that are really handy
or make it more cumbersome that it needs to
be. There is a lot of design that is gone
into this responsive piece because there's
a lot of information on these PubMed screens.
How to present that information on a mobile
design is quite a challenge.
I listed here a few of the features that are
available on mobile right now. You can log
into your my NCBI account. The advanced search
is available. We have filters and the timeline.
You can change sort order. The Cite button
is there and share is there.
You will see publisher and PMC icons. For
the first time we have those linkout library
icons so that if you are affiliated with an
institution you can have that icon on every
citation and take advantage of the subscriptions
through your institution.
Features that are still to come would be the
increased integration with my NCBI. There
were more items in this little section until
yesterday when the favorites button appeared
and the custom filters appeared. Now, really
the main push would be that Send to my bibliography
bibliography so you can send citations directly
to your NCBI bibliography.
One of the questions we hear a lot is, will
we have a single citation matcher. For those
of you who use the single citation matcher.
We still prefer you use our the title sensor
and our known item sensor in PubMed. We think
a lot of people our finding they can have
a lot of success if you can grab the first
six or seven words of the title of an article
and put it in the search box. You are likely
to get that hit in the PubMed database.
However, these tools, the search from the
MeSH database where you're able to go into
MeSH build your search and have it run into
PubMed same with the NLM catalog. The clinical
queries stool, the single citation matcher,
if you have a little citation information
and prefer to use single citation matcher
form, and the batch citation manager, these
will all be integrated with PubMed Labs when
it becomes default PubMed.
What will happen is whatever day it is that
you go to PubMed and you are presented with
this new PubMed interface, that's the same
day that when you search for MeSH your search
will be run and the results will be returned
in PubMed Labs.
People are looking for these things. They
will be linked off of the new PubMed homepage,
and that allows me to segue into the next
bullet which is the updated PubMed homepage
where working on.
When this is rolled out, or some time maybe
even prior to the rollout next year, there
will be an updated PubMed homepage. I think
seeing that homepage, seeing the tools that
you are used to seeing on that homepage, I
think, will make people happy.
And also we are working on a new PubMed API.
As I said although you see really what looks
like a refreshed interface, this is been a
rebuild from the ground up. It is in a new
environment and we need to build a new API
to support it.
Regarding the communication and planning,
in September the new PubMed will be formally
announced by NLM. That means that PubMed Labs
will have more words on it to say this is
going to become the new PubMed. Production
PubMed I anticipate will have a banner that
says, this will be replaced by the new PubMed,
and we'll encourage people to start moving
over to the new PubMed, trying it out, and
giving us more feedback. Then in January 2020
we anticipate the new PubMed will be the default.
After it becomes the default both current
and new PubMed will run in parallel for several
months. So, there is not going to be a day
when when you are presented with a new PubMed
and you cannot get back to the old PubMed.
Both systems will be there for several months.
At some point with warning current production
PubMed will be sunset.
If you would like to keep up with what is
happening with this project you can watch
for updates on PubMed Labs in NLM technical
bulletin, in the NCBI Insights blog. And on
the PubMed Labs homepage if you scroll down
we have a released features list. You can
scroll down on the homepage and see what has
happened on what has happened on a given week,
month or day.
The national network of libraries of medicine
is offering a class in September. Right now
we have scheduled four sessions. They have
four sessions scheduled that you will see
if you follow this link. if those sessions
fill up we will add more or we will increase
the attendance of there. Somehow we will accommodate
everyone who is an advanced user of PubMed
and is concerned about things like changes
in syntax. I know one thing we have done that
is to integrate more British to English mapping,
more synonymy, more Stemming for example,
more consistent mapping of singular to plural,
and that kind of thing. Those are really the
details that we'd go into in a session like
that a little bit later on.
That is what I had scheduled for today. I
can hear Jessica has been typing the whole
time I was talking, so I think we have questions.
I can see if there is anything more that I
can answer for you in the next few minutes.
The question was, with the name labs we dropped?
Yes, absolutely will. This will be just PubMed.
It won't even be new PubMed, it will just
be PubMed.
There have been some questions about integration
of other systems with PubMed. First I will
talk about the MeSH and NLM catalog where
you can run a search in those databases and
it goes to PubMed and you see your results.
It will just be redirected to the new PubMed
like the rest of the world is. That should
be pretty seamless. You will be using the
tool you are used to whether single citation
matcher or MeSH database, then when you hit
search you will go to the new PubMed where
you will see your results.
There was another part of the question? The
my NCBI, I've had a lot of people ask me if
they are going to lose their saved searches.
Again, no, that is just redirected to the
new PubMed. Your my NCBI is not going anywhere,
not being modified or moved. It's just going
to be integrated with the new database.
One thing I did not mention regarding labs,
which I really was remiss in doing. If you
saw during the slides and I will go back to
them quickly. On the bottom of every page
in labs there is a feedback button, and it
floats with you. If you scroll down it will
stay there where you can see it.
I don't know if you can see it now in the
bottom of my screen there. When you click
on feddback to send us questions about labs
those actually go to the people in this room.
So that's Kathy Canese, Jessica Chan and myself
will get those questions and we're answering
those. Regarding the link out transition,
the same thing is, if you write to the help
desk with a link out question you will get
response directly from that team. We're transitioning
from the link out where we have kept libraries
holding to the outside tool only. That transition
is underway. We transitioned hundreds of libraries
at this point, have moved over, using a link
resolver, And using an outside tool service,
and we are still planning to transition at
the end of the calendar year where the link
out local holdings well not be available anymore,
so at that point we encourage everyone to
have switched over to an outside tool link
resolver.
So, I'm going to try this but no promises.
If you are in labs, I guess I should do, yeah,
I cannot cheat and just use the canned. If
I find a MeSH indexed record, and I'm looking
at it and scroll drown, this is nice because
I wanted to show you the similar articles.
You can see the publication type MeSH terms.
If you have been a long-term user of the labs
you would notice these MeSH terms used to
appear almost like a pill shape. It was that
pill button. We updated that so if you click
on this caret you have the same actions that
were available in production PubMed. You can
search for that term in PubMed. You can search
for the term in MeSH, or you can add it to
your search.
That functionality has been improved just
this week I think this went live as well.
When you, if I run my search again If you
are saving to a file and you choose that RIS
format that is available, that is very similar
to the Medline format that you see in PubMed
today, except it is an industry standard,
so it actually improves the integration with
those citation manager programs, because we're
using industry standard for that sort of format
where you have the field tag and then the
data.
Do you know when the recording will be available?
The person who is responsible for that is
not in the room and I do not want to speak
for him. A couple of days next week. It's
already Wednesday, so maybe early next week
the recording will be available.
And I believe if you are registered for the
webinar you will get that recording link sent
to you.
Can you please repeat about title search or
known item search that you recommended instead
of sigle citation matcher.
There is a title sensor in PubMed, a citation
matcher in PubMed. I've had people say well
I use single citation matcher because I need
to find a bunch, you know, 60 citations and
I put the title in single citation matcher.
I was just going to start with just the title.
If I put a title in there, you can see here
that at the top of my results one article
found my citation matching. The other thing
you can also do is in that title matcher works
pretty well if you have most of the title.
More than six or seven words but the other
thing that you can do is sort of this Smith.
So I've got an author name, a journal and
a year, so it's pretty smart figuring out
with that citation matcher that I am looking
for articlwes by the author Smith, in Science
and in the year 2000.
It is 11:30. That went by quickly. Thank you
all for coming. There is an Encore presentation
of this if you have colleagues who missed
it and don't want to listen to a recording,
we will do this again on August 20 because
the registration was full for this one. If
you want to let people know about that, and
I appreciate everyone being here today. If
you have any feedback for us go ahead and
use the feedback link and look for the recording
for this webinar next week.